oh it must be nice to come home from  college to see a family a kid oh listen  I'm only here to sleep late and have mom  do my laundry all right  you know this country's going down with  a crapper  he was watching the news yesterday and  they've got these reared up mmm that  turkey smells good hey grandpa I'm  changing the subject before you say  something super racist sweetheart did  you want to bring some leftovers home oh  sure if you have any so what's new with  you  are you seeing anyone I bet you are yeah  I am she's pretty great we've talked on  OKCupid four times I just want to say  from the bottom of my heart I love  having you here Merry Christmas  get the hell out of my house and don't  come back for a year